that he has the ability he's already in
that category of the guy who would
completely be absolutely i know how many
like when we go out how many women are
like looking at him it's like it's not
the guy is looking at me it's the women
and i i sit there and i watch that
that's what makes me know yes he has got
the ability to cheat and yes i will
admit yeah in a way it does make him
more attractive but it doesn't i don't
think
i totally hear what you're saying and i
understand how you're trying to help me
but i just
don't think that sitting there having a
conversation going here's your your
green card from me i think he'd actually
like might even lose respect for me i i
i think that is a high possibility i
would respect you more because you
understand how the world actually works
i really like you may have that view but
i think that you you know your man
exactly and you know what that feeling
is and it probably does need to be a
conversation but to give him that kind
of pass and he's going to fall more in
love with you and unlock this chamber of
his heart that he has fastened away and
it's all going to open up and
no you know what you know what i think i
just don't think that's reality i think
the reason why you deal
you want to deal with it that's that's
my thing you don't have to sit down and
have that conversation if this is what
you choose you don't have to sit down
and have that conversation that is your
choice can i can i can i make one point
and i love justin i think justin's
absolutely bang on with with with most
of what he's saying but there is one
small point that concerns me adjusted
and that is that if you get a girl who
feels like she's too much of a pushover
basically i i've lost attraction for
women not because they've sat me down
and had a conversation said i don't care
if you cheat but i've lost sort of
desire for women if i felt that they
were too there for me do you know what i
mean if they don't hold anything back
you know you think she's she's there
i've got her on to the next one do you
know what i mean he knows that he knows
that already with me he knows that i'm
there one hundred percent okay well if i
if i push that like more like we're just
just if that like
but don't you think don't don't you
think we all have that desire to chase
for the sort of the other the
unattainable to some extent i mean when
when a woman is sort of
somewhat she holds something back that
seems to me to increase the desire when
there's a girl she's just like
completely all over me
i just sort of
i can sometimes lose interest a little
bit but i think the only thing i would
say is it depends in what stage you are
if i was looking for a serious right
this is going to be the woman yeah so
that's why i think that trying to be a
hero thing is is so important and always
be doing this because what gets me
excited about being in this my
particular relationship is i get so
excited about going out and
slaying dragons and hunting and coming
back home be like look how i've leveled
it up again i've leveled it up again
yeah again again again and that's my
responsibility so i get really happy
when i feel like i'm doing a good job
for her in that way
i think a large reason why you think
that a man
would lose respect for you
if you allowed him to go out and cheat
is because if we flipped that scenario
on its head
and you were with a guy
and he said hey baby
go out and
climb on as many dicks as you want
you would lose respect for him
church and i think that you are
interpreting this
through your personal
female lens
whereas it's a very different
perspective
could be yeah but i don't think um
i just think some people actually who
sign up for monogamy are fully fledged
this is what i want and i don't
subscribe to the thing that all men are
going to cheat i think there are some
people it comes apart of their loyalty
their integrity their morality is all
tied in and they are not they're not
going to be like oh this is okay
even to bring it up it's just like no i
don't want to do that it's not okay and
then they're going to start second
guessing so what's this one on i just
don't think it's as clear-cut as you're
making it out i think all men i don't i
kind of i do agree and disagree with it
i think i don't think that all men want
to cheat
because i think most men feel guilty
about the idea of cheating on the act
just the pure idea of it they have guilt
associated with it
and so they don't it's not because they
don't have the lust the last is still
we said that i think that goes for
everybody right
lots of us want stuff and we are never
ever going to get it i don't think women
say i'm saying i think women have like
they're we're hypergamous so it's it's i
don't want to say it's the same thing
because you're right men have a higher
sex drive than women but like women
always want the next best thing like the
next best guy
what but that is still one guy not
everything oh sure yeah
but i'm saying there's always going to
be a better guy
what we don't we don't want anyone else
when we're in a relationship with that
guy we have absolutely
zero interest that's why we're doing
i think it also goes back to the idea
that women do the monkey branch team
when they
hold on to one and they swing onto
another whereas men if they could they
would hold as many branches absolutely
as they could they would octopus exactly
but all is that as just sexual partners
or is it yeah just sexually it's just
sexual partners it's the idea that women
will always want to stick to one man so
they will monkey branch knowing that
they will end up with the highest
valuable man they want
men it goes back to the point of the
title of the today's message
men
or women cheat however men would
exercise options most men don't have the
opportunity or the ability to cheat if
they had the ability to it would be an
option to do so they know that
as a high-value man most men that are
able to cheat would be high-value men
they have options and the woman that is
coming to their side
will have to understand that this is who
they are this is how the world works i'm
in high demand if i can give you
a certain level a certain lifestyle
and in return this is what i expect love
included love included love included
yeah and i think like if you want to do
that i mean i
i get it like if a one percent guy if
you've gone through all the work to get
to where you are and you can do that and
that's what you want to do i don't like
i'm never going to shame a guy for
wanting to do that
right but i think going back to what you
were saying about paul's dad because
paul's very much like my father is i do
kind of get what justin's saying there
with if our dads were
their age
now
with
having options of women all over the
world not just like in our towns i think
things could have been like it's also
not just it's being different it's also
not just his options
it's the options that all the women he's
interacting with have
that changes the game entirely yeah
because he's not the only one with
options every single woman with an
instagram account has options well
guarantee if anyone any woman in this
room opens up their dms and we go for
that message requests i guarantee no no
i guarantee
there's dudes who are like oh you're
beautiful there's always there's always
guys hovering always yeah yeah there's
always that letters but they're played
by the old they're reading the as ryder
massey would say the old set of books
there was there was the old rule book
was like justin said monogamy you know
it was societally enforced it was
enforced with with shame and to some
extent with religion although the
influence of religion has receded you
know over the last century but you know
we're now in this sort of
we're now in cardi b world aren't we
where it's like everything's out the
window do you know what i mean like
anything goes now there is no societal
really shaming about anything really
and therefore what justin is saying
makes is is correct because it's
actually in that environment it's
actually better to be honest and just
own it and just say look i'm a guy the
reality is you know biologically we want
to spread our seed that's my program
however i love you you're my main goal
it's the deceit that bothers people and
that's that's my problem and that's why
i respectfully because i mean you have
something that many many people don't
have in a 20-year marriage i super
respect that
i would also say it's probably sight
guide so i didn't catch your age how old
are you
41 i'm going to be
next week yeah so but but it's not
okay the majority of my friends are in
the same position okay
and respectfully the reason i i don't
think that i'm trying to be manipulative
number one i got no skin in the game but
number two it is very glaringly obvious
that there is this wedge between you
that's being unspoken
and you've also said because of who he
is as a man and that you know that he's
probably doing it you still are not
gonna leave so if he's gonna do it
and you're not gonna leave why are you
torturing yourself and not just ripping
the band-aid off
and
giving the communication part of your
relationship an opportunity because i
promise you if you if you address it
every at least once maybe twice maybe
three times however many it takes that
feeling will go away
because you would have already addressed
it you have uncovered that you've cut
the lights on the boogeyman is not there
anymore you know he's doing it and you
know you're not going to leave so why
why i suffer
why i don't understand i'm not trying to
manipulate her i'm not trying to look
because
i got no skin honest i would yeah
exactly i i would suffer like for
if it was okay i'm gonna give you two
scenarios
if it wasn't happening
then that's basically giving a pass to
him that i'm still gonna be here if you
go and do that okay that's if it's not
happening if it is happening
for me that is more pain
would be to have that conversation
acknowledging because then she knows
like yeah but and then it's just yeah it
makes it real more pain happens while
people are thinking about things
then i i i i think i think that's a
different word
completely change everything
and that's why it could be one
conversation hey i know you're probably
doing this i love you i'll never leave
you okay
like what i'm saying to you that kind of
underlying anxiety all the time you guys
in red pearl talk about it all the time
like competition anxiety i'm always you
know in the salon i'm always trying to
get things done i'm always trying you
know it's constant and i keep doing that
i keep doing that to kind of
feel better in myself but it's mainly
for him are you gonna are you gonna quit
doing that if you found out he's not
cheating
if i found out he yeah no i would never
quit i would never quit doing it no way
but if he
was doing it
it wouldn't be that do you know what i
mean it's that that feeling like yeah
i'm gonna go get how's that gonna look
good i'm gonna have these injectables
but then if i knew he was if i knew he
was doing it i'd almost be there sitting
like
chopping the potato for dinner being
like
like
rather than like you know why am i i
would kind of feel this is
there'd be a reality that this is a
really hard life and he could leave at
any time i'd rather just
like all girls like to live in some kind
of even if it's a fantasy that's where
we like to be at all right yeah it's
really hard to explain i've been cheated
on and i'm going to tell you my life was
a lot better before i knew
i was like
it's like i think that's the reality for
most people that's why i was hearing you
and i'm like
yeah she does this it is unhealthy not
to have the conversation but this is
what's so interesting is she is a woman
is telling you exactly how she feels in
a very cohesive clear way and you're
just saying it's something else it's
it's just not like then what is it so
what i'm hearing from a lot of you guys
is that you would much rather be lied to
it no no no no i think it it depends on
the person and what's at stake do you
know what i mean she's described her
relationship like he's a high value man
and she's a good man he's a good man
she's not earning that much do you know
me she's got a lot to lose if the
relationship doesn't go well that's her
situation that's her therefore she needs
to she needs to she needs to wait up her
options so what he's saying doesn't
necessarily mean that's right for her
relationship it might be right for
someone else but not necessarily her do
you see what i mean that's not hard i
don't think you're wrong actually i
think it's true what hurts for me is i
hate i hate to see another human hurting
when you could just be honest and maybe
that's a man pragmatic type thing that's
less emotional so if that is the answer
for you and you you want this amount of
pain that you're going through
is worth not knowing the truth and and
that's better than knowing the truth the
truth may hurt more and lost
can i just say this point as well
because it's interesting to me because
i've been in the situation as i said
before that i've been cheated on and
like and i've been in a situation where
a guy's been really upfront and saying
this is this is what it is do you agree
or disagree and stuff it doesn't hurt
any less
do you know what i mean it doesn't
actually hurt any less the act of that
happening to me wasn't do you know it
didn't make me feel oh like because he
told me i respect him more no it didn't
it just made me feel like oh [ __ ] i've
actually agreed to this and this is
what's happening [ __ ] like do not be
like it's just i was annoyed at myself
that i even
entered the relationship were you
when when when he when he said this was
it it was at the beginning so i went
into it but it didn't hurt any less do
you see what i mean what did he say
though did he say i want to be
non-monogamous
i'm not gonna you know i'm gonna be yeah
playing around essentially
my brother had that my brother had this
the other day he he's he was dating this
girl they've met up quite a few times
and
she basically has turned around to him
and said look like you're rare i don't
mind waiting for you and he's just like
look like you know i am dating other
women she's going oh i don't care like
you're right but i think that i
understand that because there isn't as
much like investment there straight away
do you know what i mean yeah
i think in the early days it's different
isn't it the early days is different
because you guys are still kind of
semi-independent or whatever well
they're not that it's happening with me
with change
it's very clear what what's going on
here
you're okay with it because of the value
exchange a lot of times women leave men
that cheat because he cheated and the
exchange of value
doesn't balance out
when she finds out he's cheating because
she was
taking some of the value of sexual
exclusivity into the equation but when a
man so far surpasses the value the woman
doesn't care and she stays which is
exactly what you're doing
because if a lesser man were cheating on
you you would leave his ass